si vous voulez mettre hors d'état de
nuire les délinquants il faut
réhabiliter les courtes peines de prison
ces courtes peines de prison qui ne sont
plus jamais exécuté depuis notamment
christiane taubira alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait alors tout le monde vous promet des
milliers de places emmanuel macron a
promis 15000 places de prisons elles
sont où il a promis 56 centres éducatifs
fermés pour les mineurs ils sont où
alors nous allons promettre de réaliser
vingt mille places de prison
supplémentaires et nous les ferons mais
elles sortiront pas de terre dès l'été
est ce que veulent les français c'est
des résultats tout de suite on est en
crise d'autorité on a envie l'impunité
permanente des délinquants alors comment
est ce qu'on va faire eh bien on va
ouvrir des centres de détention
provisoire dans des bâtiments
désaffectés avec l'aide de la
pénitentiaire est dans ces centres de
détention provisoire où on mettra des
délinquants des primes au condamné des
courtes peines sous bracelet
électronique
parce que aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe ils n'exécuteront pas leur peine
on leur met à la cheville un bracelet
électronique et on les renvoie dans leur
quartier vous imaginez la détresse des
habitants et vous croyez que c'est les
empêche de continuer leurs trafics c'est
bracelet électronique à la cheville
c'est venu trophée des caïds alors nous
on va les utiliser autrement et on va
créer ces centres de prison provisoire
immédiatement de façon à mettre hors
d'état de nuire les délinquants et à
exécuter enfin les peines de prison